[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 13 février bienvenue dans
le journal de tv 78 voici les titres de
l'actualité locale la saint valentin
c'est demain mais la fête des amoureux a
déjà été célébré le week-end dernier
dans les refuges spa avec la
saint-valentin des animaux retour sur
cette opération à plaisir et le point
dans cette édition sur les adoptions fin
février l'équipe de france de cyclisme
sur piste seront engagées dans les
championnats du monde à tokyo à berlin
avant les jo de tokyo
c'est bien là berlin hier les noms à des
membres de la sélection tricolore pour
les mondiaux ont été dévoilées et tu la
page dédiée aux municipales à la
verrière c'est le quatrième candidat
pour le scrutin gérard claude morvan est
à la tête et de la liste à la verrière
citoyenne il a été premier adjoint du
maire dans les années 1980 et puis
quelques idées de sortir aussi à suivre
dans ce journal
christophe castaner dans les yvelines ce
jeudi le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
déplacé sur le thème de la prise en
charge des femmes victimes de violences
sexuelles et sexistes visite à la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique à viroflay puis au centre
hospitalier andré mignot sur place une
convention a été signée pour l'accueil
et la prise des plaintes des victimes de
violences conjugales au sein des
établissements de santé et disposition
suite au grenelle des violences
conjugales qui a eu lieu en fin d'année
dernière retrouvez un reportage complet
dans notre émission demain le 7 8 c'est
l'hebdo les salariés d'un sous-traitant
de renault en grève depuis lundi matin
les employés de vestale ya une filiale
de veolia ont entamé un mouvement
illimité ils dénoncent la dégradation de
leurs conditions de travail et demandent
une augmentation salariale ces personnes
s'inquiètent également d'un accord sur
le temps de travail qui prévoit des
semaines allant de 28 à 44 heures des
rythmes qui s'adapte à la cadence voulue
par renault sur la production des
négociations devaient avoir lieu
aujourd'hui avec la direction est la
saint valentin c'est demain vendredi les
animaux eux l'ont fêtée déjà le week-end
dernier 66 refuge spa de france propose
l opération saint valentin des animaux
parmi lesquels celui de plaisir et il ya
la responsable de ce refuge avec non en
plateau marie-laure carbone
voir ça comment s'est déroulée cette
opération pour le refuge de plaisir nous
sommes plutôt assez content de notre
week-end puisque nous avons pu à cette
occasion faire adopter 12 chiens et 25
chats dont des chats qui était au refuge
depuis plusieurs mois donc on est très
content qu'ils aient enfin trouvé une
famille et des chiens dont un chien qui
était relativement âgées donc on est
plutôt contents du du bilan c'est
important de proposer régulièrement il
ya des d'autres week end adoption de
proposer ce genre d'animation alors
c'est vrai que tous les week-ends comme
ça sur un sujet particulier on a
tendance à cibler quand même beaucoup
plus de visiteurs donc potentiellement
on fait quand même beaucoup plus
d'adoption et des adoptions sur place et
ce qu'il y avait aussi des animations
spéciales prévues à l'occasion de cette
saint valentin des animaux effectivement
donc on avait une autre petite buvette
avec vente de crêpes crêpes garni sucrés
et salés et puis les adoptants on
pouvait se faire prendre en photo avec
justement une petite décoration spéciale
saint valentin pour voir si c'est un
match et avec les animaux notamment
alors il ya eu beaucoup de communication
qui a été fait là dessus par la spa en
ce début d'année 2020 est ce que les
adoptions sont nombreuses alors en
mettant de côté ce week-end mais ce que
elles sont nombreuses
vu que les fait maintenant son passé ce
que lcl se maintiennent les adoptions
oui sourire on trouve que voilà on fait
le même taux d'adoption que l'année
dernière en sachant quand même que
l'année 2019 a été comme une
on est assez exceptionnel au niveau des
adoptions donc on espère toujours faire
mieux donc on espère pour 2020 faire
beaucoup plus d'adoption et ce après les
fêtes
malheureusement il ya aussi une hausse
des abandons ou c'est plutôt quelque
chose qu'on voit avant les grandes
vacances
en général c'est plutôt ciblé au niveau
des vacances d'été là on n'a pas été
trop marqué par par les départs par le
père noël partout ça donc on espère que
ça n'empire pas
on rappelle que la mission bien sûr de
l'aespa l'une des missions elles sont
nombreuses c'est de recueillir et
héberger ces animaux abandonnés perdus
ou maltraitées sont combien d'animaux
environ qui sont recueillis à plaisir à
plaisir on récupère environ fait adopter
en 2000 animaux par an donc on en
récupère autant on a un équilibre entre
les entrées les sorties et plus on en
fait adopter plus on peut en sauver donc
donc on va dire que c'est à peu près 800
800 chiens par par parents et 1000 1200
ch apparent donc c'est essentiellement
des chiens et des chats ya d'autres
animaux malheureusement tous abandonne
donc nous avons aussi des nac les
nouveaux animaux de compagnie donc on a
aussi des lapins des cochons d'inde des
furets des rats alors le refuge de
plaisir a été le théâtre d'une émission
de télévision qui est passé sur ces 8
est ce que ça ça dope et les adoptions
est-ce que vous en avez profité
alors oui ça nous a aidés justement le
principe de participer à cette émission
c'était aussi de faire connaître la spa
le combat de la spa donc ça pue ça fait
quand même changé les mentalités donc on
est très content du résultat
il ya des personnes qui sont venues au
refuge en disant qu'il voulait acheter
dans une animalerie et se sont rendus
compte que ce n'était pas forcément une
bonne chose
donc oui c'est plutôt positif la spa
d'ailleurs milité pour l'adoption
responsable qu'est ce que ça veut dire
alors l'adoption responsable c'est à
dire que
c'est ce qu'on explique aux adoptants on
n'est pas un entrepôt d'animaux où ils
viennent ils prennent s'ils veulent non
on est là nous pour les guider et le
retrouver l'animal qui leur correspond
le mieux en fonction de l'heure de leur
condition de vie du temps qu'ils ont
consacré on essaie de ont fait des
mariages nous aussi c'est ce qu'on
appelle des mariages soit on essaie de
trouver la bonne famille pour le bon
animal et surtout il faut une bonne
réflexion aussi avant de l'adopter ça ne
se fait pas comme ça ça il faut il faut
bien réfléchir pour ça qu'ils ont les
projette aussi dans le futur puisque il
faut penser aux vacances il faut penser
éventuellement une naissance proches le
travail voilà il faut que les gens se
rendent compte que leur animal c'est
quand même pour plusieurs années et si
on veut adopter comment fait-on vient
directement sur le sur le reçu au refuge
spa
oui donc aller les personnes peuvent se
présentent au refuge ont fait remplir un
petit questionnaire ça nous permet de
savoir dans quelles conditions vivre à
l'animal pour mieux les guider les
renseigner et puis si tout correspond
ils peuvent partir avec l'animal le jour
même donc ça peut être très rapide
est ce qu'il ya des frais pour pour
l'adoption on demande une participation
de 250 euros pour l'adoption d'un chien
et 150 euros pour un chat en sachant que
ça comprend l'identification la
vaccination et la stérilisation
donc on l'a dit est l'une des missions
l'accueil de ces animaux aussi leur
trouver une nouvelle famille c'est aussi
faire évoluer la cause animale c'est
l'une des missions de la espère auprès
des pouvoirs publics en ile de france il
y à un tiers des foyers qui possèdent un
chat ou un chien un chien ou un chat
pardon valérie pécresse qui est
présidente de la région ile de france a
soumis une idée cette semaine celle
peut-être de mettre en place ce qu'on
appellerait un permis d'adopter pour
lutter contre les abandons et les cas de
maltraitance malheureusement de nombreux
cas de maltraitance encore cette semaine
dans les yvelines à poissy il ya des
dispositifs similaires qui existe en
belgique et en allemagne est ce que ce
serait une bonne chose une bonne chose
de mettre en place en france
je pense que ce serait une bonne chose
parce qu'il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose c'est à dire que nous là on se
sent impuissant
on a l'impression que malheureusement
moment donné ça se reproduit sans cesse
donc effectivement si des personnes qui
ont maltraité un animal non plus le
droit de détenir 1 à nîmes
elle ça pourrait faire évoluer les
choses positivement merci marie laure
caron d'être venu sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes la responsable du
refuge spa de plaisir on retrouve bien
sûr un toutes les informations sur ce
refus sur le site internet qui s'affiche
à l'écran
merci on parlait de la saint valentin
des animaux demain c'est la saint
valentin tout court c'est demain
vendredi plus de 80 % des français
considèrent cette fête comme commercial
même si la plupart la célèbre et vous
allez est ce que vous vous allez marquer
le coup pour cette saint valentin
marylène yapi chinois et nicolas kirilow
vides sont allés poser la question à
quelques saint quentinois regarder n'ont
même pas je pense pas c'est devenu trop
commercial c'est pas quelque chose qui
nous qui nous attire on largue la petite
avoir l'aîné et du coup on ne fait
jamais rien de très spécial parce a
enfin fait des trucs toute l'année donc
pas besoin pour la saint valentin un
petit resto puis ensuite une soirée en
amoureux
tin oo un petit goût de fleurs aussi
pour moi ça fait toujours plaisir
j'apprécie avant mais après par la suite
du compris que ça ne servait pas
vraiment
bon idéologie de l'élection créé 2 de
l'amour quoi aussi quand la saint
valentin c'est demain donc je vais pas
la fêter c'était une blague en fait une
courbe on peut se faire des cadeaux tout
au long de l'année il n'y a pas de
besoin d'attendre dans le 14 février
pour faire se faire des cadeaux
on aime bien sortir donc on profite de
ces trucs là pour voilà puis
généralement dents serrées dans les
restaurants ils font toujours un petit
menu adapté cette soirée là et c'est
sympa quoi moi je vais sortir le grand
jeu un soir je met ma petite tenue rouge
et où moi je vois pas l'intérêt vraiment
une fête géante a maintenant on fait une
fête pour 6 défaites pour ça non je vois
pas du tout l'intérêt
bon ça fait du commerce c'est tout moi
je préfère le petit truc à la maison
avec un petit cadeau éventuellement ou
un petit bouquet de fleurs et puis voilà
quoi
la saint valentin qui ne sera pas au
coeur demain vendredi du 7-8 échos
l'émission sera consacrée à la
transformation digitale et des petites
et moyennes entreprises ainsi que des
artisans comment les entrepreneurs de ce
type utilisent les outils numériques
éléments de réponse avec nicolas d'andry
la transformation numérique pour les tpe
pme artisans consiste à s'approprier les
bénéfices que vont pouvoir tirer ces
professionnels des différents outils
numériques qui correspondent à leur
métier
pour le commerçant ça va être de pouvoir
faire de la vente en ligne pour des
clients qui sont peut-être pas proximité
de chez eux de façon à pouvoir élargir
son sa clientèle les meilleurs moyens
pour faire sa transition numérique et de
regarder ce que font ses confrères et le
deuxième c'est de se documenter et de
suivre éventuellement soit des tutoriels
soit des formations en ligne
les artisans qui ne s'approprie pas le
numérique aujourd'hui risque de se faire
hubert hysek parce qu'ils vont le faire
donc ça peut être une question de survie
et les outils numériques qui permettent
de faciliter le collaboratif sont plus
en plus important les réseaux sociaux y
contribuer notamment et ça beaucoup
d'entreprises aujourd'hui n'ont pas
conscience de l'importance que ça peut
avoir en france le coût de la compétence
informatique de 1500 euros par an par
salarié
ce chiffre a tout simplement été obtenue
en regardant en étudiant quel était le
temps perdu par les salariés dans les
entreprises à faire une tâche quand ils
ne connaissaient pas bien l'outil
informatique qui leur permettait de bien
faire cette page ou de la faire
rapidement le sport direction le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la liste des
coureurs français retenus pour les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste a été dévoilée hier mercredi une
compétition au programme fin février à
berlin le reportage de nickel et demi
d'euros et de patrick jacques de dixmude
une conférence de presse à temps dieu la
sélection piste pour les championnats du
monde de berlin était dévoilée ce rendez
vous organisé du 26 février au 1er mars
fera office de test à quelques mois des
jeux olympiques
on a une équipe de france qui est très
bien dans sa trajectoire par rapport à
tokyo et du coup qui va aborder ces
championnats du monde à la fois pour y
faire des résultats pour performer est
ce que c'est important est à la fois
également je pense pour prendre de
l'assurance la confiance à huy a besoin
dans la construction vert
tokyo sur les épreuves d'endurance on
retrouvera notamment à certains bryan
coquard champion du monde en 2015 sur la
piste du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
je me sens plutôt bien à vrai dire j'ai
crié est repris l'entraînement va dire
le 1er décembre
et voilà ces derniers entraînements sur
piste sont plutôt plutôt encourageant je
participerai à la course aux points au
championnat du monde je suis champion
d'europe en titre
bien évidemment j'ai envie d envie de
bien faire du côté du sprint pas de
surprise on retrouve les désormais
incontournables grégory baugé sébastien
vigion ou encore mathilde de gros mais
l'une des stars de cette équipe de
france sera quentin lafargue et binoy
licencié au vc jusqu'à y avait remporté
l'or sur le kilomètre et large en
vitesse par équipes sur les derniers
mondiaux en 2019
c'est toujours un moment important cette
sélection est et ce champion du monde
tous les ans qui revient mais qui fait
toujours plaisir à afin de porter porté
les couleurs des équipes de france au
plus haut niveau donc je l'attendais je
l'espérais et je suis content de faire
partie du collectif la fédération
française n'a pas voulu annoncer
d'objectif chiffré de médailles sur les
championnats du monde les premières
épreuves sont programmées le mercredi 26
février à partir de 13 heures
[Musique]
elle les vacances continuent pour les
yvelinois et bien sûr de nombreuses
activités sont prévues bon sens mais les
nippes ok qu'avez vous à nous proposer
pour votre sélection d'idées de sorties
alors vous devez vous en douter grégory
il ya beaucoup d'animations une fois
encore je ne serai pas exhaustive le
premier rendez vous que j'ai à vous
proposer se passe à plaisir
l'association impro net organise un
stage de découverte de l'un près de
l'improvisation
il s'adresse aux jeunes âgés de 10 à 15
ans pendant cette semaine ils vont
pouvoir durant deux heures par jour
travailler des exercices d'improvisation
tout en s'amusant ils vont pouvoir
savoir mettre en scène des histoires
jouer des personnages interagir entre
eux créent aussi une cohésion entre dans
le groupe qui va être fort mais il reste
encore quelques places pour les
intéressés clou du stage les jeunes
artistes présenteront leur travail à
leurs familles et amis le vendredi on
continue mélanie avec les châteaux qui
sont aussi à la fête
et oui celle-là on part à rambouillet où
les équipes vous ont concocté une chasse
au trésor il va falloir trouver un
trésor ancestrale qui se transmet depuis
des siècles entre les propriétaires du
château vous serez aider dans votre
quête par une jeune historienne madame
pivert c'est un moment à vivre en
famille du lundi 17 au samedi 22 février
l'animation se fait par contre sur
réservation uniquement
et un dernier rendez-vous de châtelet on
va plus au nord du département et oui là
on part au château de maisons plus
exactement la magie du rococo va vous
être dévoilé à travers un atelier
vacances cet atelier commence par la
visite de l'exposition fantaisie pour un
palais et après ces deux se visitent un
moment de création manuelle les enfants
confectionneront un pop-up illusionniste
et bien sûr rococo c'est un moment à
vivre
les 14 19 20 et 21 février merci mélanie
pour ses idées de sorties on l'espère
avec un week-end plus cléments côté
météo pour d'autres suggestions vous
retrouve bien sûr dans votre émission le
7-8 ce loisir 7 après journal
[Musique]
mais d'abord la partie de cette édition
dédiée aux élections municipales premier
tour le 15 mars prochain à saint cyr
l'école
sonia broc maire sortante a commencé des
opérations de tractage dans le cadre de
la campagne allait à la rencontre et des
saint cyriens pour avoir la vie des
habitants et finalisé son programme
mathilde demi opération porte-à-porte
pour la maire sortante de saint cyr
l'école qui a lancé sa liste en décembre
dernier avec son équipe
saint cyr au coeur 2020 sonia brouch
rencontrent les habitants avec
l'objectif de les faire participer à la
construction de son programme
les points essentiels du rôle du
programme vont être de remettre l'humain
au centre de saint siège on a on vienne
pas ses deux mandats
à construire parce que l'état comme vous
le savez nous demander de densifier nous
sommes en deuxième couronne il y a
vraies difficultés pour se loger en
région parisienne cette fois ci bien
maintenant il va on va pouvoir se
consacrer au saint cyrien et aux
services qu'on lui propose dans son
triptyque elle met un point d'honneur à
lutter contre l'incivisme et les
dégradations du quotidien à valoriser le
tissu économique local ou encore
revaloriser le patrimoine sincères ayant
l'idée phare c'est vraiment de
construire un centre ville de
redynamiser le commerce est d'arriver à
une vie de ville dans laquelle on fait
des choses ont fait pas que venir dormir
à partir travailler et où on a envie
d'aller au cinéma au théâtre se promener
un petit peu dans nos parcs puisqu'on en
a quand même de très jolis pour saint
cyr au coeur 2020 les opérations de
tractage continue jusqu'à la fin du mois
et une réunion publique se tiendra le 27
février prochain pour l'instant
seulement deux listes se sont déclarés
dans la commune de saint cyr l'école à
la verrière on devrait se diriger vers
un duel à 4 pour ces élections
municipales bonsoir gérard claude morfin
vous êtes bonjour bonsoir vous êtes la
tête de liste de la verrière citoyenne
pour le scrutin je précise que vous êtes
également le président de l'association
citoyenne vous avez été adjointe au
maire premier adjoint de 1983 à 1989
adjoint de 95 à 2001 puis vous avez
siéger dans l'opposition entre 2001 et
2008 à chaque fois avec pierre celle un
cours comme maire pourquoi pourquoi
revenir en politique
vous avez bien réviser votre sujet
pourquoi revenir d'abord parce que je ne
suis jamais parti et que
je suis peut-être un peu addicts du
phénomène parce que je continue à
assister aux conseils municipaux et au
conseil d'agglomération
des éléments qui m'amène à revenir comme
vous dites
ben des faits qui sont qui me gêne un
peu comme notamment la démolition la
destruction du sens bazire du bois de
l'étang
on a six problèmes de sons c'est
peut-être dû à votre porte
on va vous demander de la grangette dans
votre vie vous l'avez dit pas de
peut-être de couper même on le dit et
dans laurier soucis techniques
on va essayer de régler ça
vous l'avez dit pardon la destruction du
centre de loisirs du bois de l'étang on
va reprendre le cours normal de cette
interview avait été construit entre 1977
et 1983 par des élus socialistes et
communistes qui a été démolie pour des
raisons obscures alors que rien ne
prédispose est ce cet équipement public
à disparaître
un autre point c'est la promotion
immobilière à tout va qui envahit le
quartier du bois de l'étang parce que il
ya autre chose à faire que de
ne pas résister - immobilière sachant qu
étant ne l'est pas demandé mais de
profession architectes et urbanistes
j'ai un avis forcément sur la question
sur la question d'ailleurs je vais la
trouver de quoi vous êtes gêné un petit
peu c'est l'opacité de l'information
communal de plus en plus qui est qui et
qui présente ici on parle d'urbanisme
justement sur le dossier du bois de
l'étang qui est bien sûr au coeur d'un
projet de rénovation urbaine
vous êtes vous contre une démolition des
bâtiments plutôt pour une rénovation de
ses bâtiments au bord de l'étang c'est
ça écoutez ma spécificité c'est j'ai
habité pendant 18 ans quartier ce qui
n'est pas le cas des trois autres
candidats d'une part et d'autre part il
ya des choses à faire effectivement mais
qui ne sont pas celles là
donc effectivement réhabilitation
intérieure rénovation
partiel l'extérieur il planté par
exemple centre commercial à ne pas
démolir bien évidemment mais à restaurer
et puis changer des éléments dur les
éléments d'équipement des bâtiments
l'ascenseur colonne sèche qui ont plus
de 50 ans d'âge ou presque et qui
normalement dont la durée de vie de
l'ordre de 30 à 35 ans et sur le dossier
l'urbanisme si on parle aussi d'un autre
grand projet à la verrière c'est ce
projet de gare bécane la zone guerre
bécane qui a été relancé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
vous voudriez voir construire sur cette
zone moitié noir moitié moins de
logements qui sont prévus il ya environ
mille logements qui sont prévues sur
place vous voudriez voir plutôt 600 650
logements maximum
c'est ça tiens comment je le sais mais
ça je veux documente c'est bien là il ya
plusieurs sujets d'importance à sur les
six ans qui viennent
à part celui ci un petit mot quand même
sur le point de lavilledieu dont j'ai
commencé à m'occuper en 1995 devrait
être doublé dont qui relie la verrière
c'est quoi c'est pas c'est pas cette
solution là qu'il faut prendre double et
non en tout cas remplacer le point
existants et le doublé oui mais pas
comme celui du pont qui jouent l'air ou
là il ya des erreurs techniques qui
auraient été réalisées après vous avez
les mâles me donne ou dans le cadre de
la consultation publique je m'étonne que
j'étais porteur d'une alternative pour
passer sous la rn 10 et puis je suis
plutôt avec mes compagnons favorable à
une extension du périmètre qui englobe
le passage souterrain actuelle sur les
voies ferrées et pour revenir sur votre
question je n'aime pas tellement le
terme guerre bécade d'abord parce que
les canes ca quartier en tant que tels
égards c'est plutôt un autre quartier
qui s'appelle l'agio et je pense que
l'histoire a son importance dans la
dénomination des dossiers dont bécane
effectivement il faut que ce soit un
quartier qui soit à l'image des deux
autres existants les trois qu'on a dans
les parcs village et voix de l'étang
honte à peu près le même poids de
population le même nombre de logements
ça serait une erreur urbanistique que de
vouloir en faire tout de suite 2000
comme c'était prévu au départ
ou 1500 comme j'ai entendu parce que la
promotion immobilière il faut lui passer
la main dans le dos mais c'est aussi un
combat c'est pas seulement dire il en
faut six ans il ya aussi les équipements
d'accompagnement scolaire sont
commerciales hélas nous promettre de
temps juste un mot sur la liste qui est
aussi important qui est une liste vous
le revendiquez ni de droite ni de gauche
c'est l'élément citoyens vous soyez vous
souhaitez mettre en avant ça veut dire
c'est davantage l'engagement citoyen
pour la commune de la verrière qui
compte plus que l'étiquette politique
m'a écouté il ya 20 ans s'est lancé dans
ce pari de la réflexion d'une
association citoyenne en été je pense un
peu en avance parce que la verticalité
politique a marqué le pas ces derniers
temps le phénomène des ronds-points
aussi montré que
le citoyen est important plus que
les lecteurs et comment dire
actuellement la citoyenneté est au
centre des préoccupations c'est les
incivilités c'est le manque de propreté
c'est les difficultés de maintenance de
notre patrimoine mobilier et immobilier
tous ajouté boutabout fait qu' il ya une
prise de conscience citoyenne et je vais
devancé votre question certainement
actuellement nous avons plus de
candidats que de places d'accord sur la
liste a été et est donc comme nous
fonctionnons en termes d'entretien entre
la tête de liste et puis le ou la
candidate
les entretiens sont pas tout à fait
terminé mais ne vous inquiétez pas il
ira unie citoyenne déposées en
préfecture sous préfecture je suis même
plus lequel le lieu précis pour montrer
qu'il ya autre chose de possible sur les
communes petites comme la variable avec
une spécificité il ya des référents par
quartier au sein de cette liste vous
avez nommé des référents par carte et
c'est c'est un petit peu l'expérience
que j'ai trouvé dans la drôme avec la
commune de saillant oui effectivement
c'est là que sont apparus des attitudes
démocratique citoyenne et et puis j'en
ai trouvé finalement cherchant un peu un
petit peu partout c'est un phénomène
d'ailleurs même sur l'agglomération de
rêve il ya des listes qui se réclament
de la citoyenneté et je trouve ça très
très fort très très bien sachant que
l'agglomération vous n'avez pas parlé
mais c'est aussi important pour pour
nous puisque ce sont des élections à la
fois municipal et communautaire on élit
également effectivement des conseillers
communautaires et j'ajoute pour terminer
cette interview que vous avez été
vice-président de ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque la ville nouvelle de saint
quentin en yvelines qui aujourd'hui une
communauté d'agglomération merci gérard
claude morfin est d'être venu en plateau
tête de liste de la verrière citoyenne
pour ces élections et sont également
candidats à la verrière la maire
sortante nelly duthu son actuel premier
adjoint jean yves blessure une autre
liste et également la candidature de
l'élue d'opposition nicolas dainville la
direction villepreux à présent pour
poursuivre notre tour d'horizon des
principaux enjeux municipal urbanisme
santé redynamisation du centre ville ont
fait le point avec or il est onze
membres de saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2016
onze mille habitants villepreux devrait
compter un nouveau quartier à l'horizon
après plusieurs mois de concertation le
projet central park avait été dévoilée
fin 2018
objectif créer une entrée de ville
urbaine et paysagère scénario choisi
pour l'aménagement du secteur élargi du
trianon 250 logements et un grand parc
urbain de 19 mille mètres carrés selon
le calendrier annoncé les travaux
devraient débuter en 2020 un projet que
souhaite voir gelée plusieurs candidats
autre thème qui s'invite dans la
campagne la santé ville prenez pas un
désert médical mais il situé dans une
zone d'action complémentaires selon la
rs la diminution du nombre de praticiens
en raison notamment des départs à la
retraite inquiète les habitants une
offre de soins jugé insuffisante qui
pourrait être étoffée avec la création
d'une maison de santé
autre enjeu la redynamisation du
centre-ville et notamment le
développement des commerces de proximité
qui souffrent de la concurrence des
zones commerciales des villes voisines
de plaisir et des clayes-sous-bois enfin
quel avenir pour le théâtre de
villepreux l'établissement culturel de
400 places ne propose plus de spectacle
depuis septembre dernier plusieurs
candidats souhaitent re développer la
culture dans la ville et notamment
réhabiliter cet espace et avant de vous
laisser je rappelle que dans le cadre de
cette campagne des municipales tv 78
avec radio sensations vous propose des
débats entre les candidats ce soir
émission consacrée à poissy demain
vendredi et des bas pour la ville de
rambouillet c'est à retrouver à chaque
fois à 20h sur tv 78 ou sur la fréquence
98.4 pour nos confrères de radio
sensations voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]